CBS News contributor ed O'Keefe is
congressional reporter for The
Washington Post head good morning good
to see you guys so what impact will CBO
report have on the bill in the Senate
well the the big impact it will have is
it sets the road map essentially 119
billion dollars is the figure to meet or
exceed and they have to do that in the
Senate in order to pass it as a budget
bill which would only require a majority
vote if you come in less than that it
would require Democratic support there
is no Democratic support for what
Republicans are doing so that's
McConnell that says he doesn't think he
can get 50 I'm glad you read that
internet because it is a very important
statement from the Senate Majority
Leader who I think very clearly is
pouring some cold water on what is now
underway in the Senate what doesn't he
like it's not that he doesn't like it
they all want to undo the Affordable
Care Act and enact some kind of
Affordable Health Care Act the problem
is among the 52 Republicans in the
Senate they just can't come to an
agreement of what exactly should be done
and when you've only got those 52 it's
it's going to be very hard to do a myth
we all remember that big celebration in
the Rose Garden when the House passed
their version there were no senators
there yeah exactly in their distance
from this they don't want anything to do
with what the house question was raised
like that time whether this is a little
bit premature yeah yeah and I think
that's what the the Senate leader is
suggesting there is that look there's a
chance that we don't pass something
comprehensive that maybe we do something
more modest but this is totally within
Republicans in the Senate as you
suggested yes yes they have to do they
have to work among themselves everyone
from Ted Cruz and Rand Paul who want to
blow up the whole thing - guys like Rob
Portman or Dean Heller from Ohio in
Nevada who take a more pragmatic
approach and are very concerned about
blowing up too much of this and
affecting the coverage do you think they
want the administration's help in
crafting their bill we'll see I think
for now they prefer the White House to
stay out of it isn't this about as you
mentioned that almost 120 billion dollar
number that they have to meet in order
to make it a budget build a lot of that
savings come from Medicaid right just
turns out that a number of these
Republican senators we're up for
reelection coming up in the next several
years have states to get a lot amount
expansion of Medicaid and not only the
ones from swing states but guys like Tom
cotton from Arkansas very conservative
state very concerned about the thousands
on his state this is the very reason
they want to go health care before tax
reform yes well that and they have to
in order to get the savings that would
that would get and get worked into tax
reform yes we talked about Montana that
you were seriously shaking your head I
know Ben Jacobs he's a great reporter he
a liberal journalist no he's he's just a
reporter who asked questions but this I
know I love the guy he's incapable of
flipping a congressional candidate who
is taller and bigger than him and that
is what that is what that campaign
suggested last night it's not true do
you think that incident is going to
affect the outcome of the race so many
people have already voted exactly 37
percent of the ballots are already in
this is a state that has more Republican
voters the Democratic voters unless
enough people are compelled to wake up
this morning and head to the polls
because of what they saw last night
either to vote for the guy or against
them we'll see you think he'll still win
well it's trending in that direction
yeah Montana in House races especially
as a Republicans have you talked to Ben
Jacob by chance I have not talked to him
but I've been with him on the trail in
the past this is a guy
johnny-on-the-spot loves to be there I'm
not surprised when I found out that he
was there that he was there and that he
was in the room trying to get this guy
to answer question ed when you and I you
still cover Congress I have in the past
it is common practice certainly on
Capitol Hill that you follow senators
around into elevators on the train and
you have a microphone in their mouth and
most of the time if this guy can't
handle one guy in Montana wait till he
gets to the speaker's Lobby there's a
dozens of us there every day so talking
about Washington know the president
comes back after the g7 meeting then
Comey testifies after Memorial Day is
there will be any time any progress
really on the only legislative agenda
for this well the Senate has about two
months they have until the August recess
begins essentially to figure out what
they're going to do about health care
that that is what top leaders told me
this week they want to get this done
before they go home for August is that
realistic is amiss that that's another
question I you know I would think that
if health care is top of mind and the
big lofty issue they want to be working
on that they can make it happen my
question is at what point do they
realize perhaps that there are certain
parts of this they just can't get an
agreement it's in the hands of Mitch
McConnell it is enhancements totally in
the hands of Mitch McConnell this is one
of the most ambitious pieces of
legislations he has had to oversee and
since he became Senate leader
Republicans have not had to do
heavy lifting on this kind of stuff
it'll be a real test for them all right
I was curious about your take on the
president's trip so far it's like it's
going all right
I hate that okay I wish I was there he's
covering right yeah he knows that me
live with our Michelle I know he knows
they ordered I know he knows other stuff
too that's why I'd love to be in
Brussels I know I'm never talking on the
green yeah got a pie here yeah
thank you very much a Paris